submitted by frown oh damn that's the
first time I did that dude never
something to hide [ __ ] coffee that
[ __ ] is crazy this crazy coffee lady I
drank I love them pretty wired in to
real news too real for steal frown
upside down
that's a smile amen was one straight
line a man was stabbed at a haunted
house after a real knife was mistaken
for a prop to you a hundred the man that
got stabbed yeah stab me bro it happened
to me in high school not that same thing
but like now it's playing touching it
right and you when you play tennis got
black 3:00 a.m. 4:00 a.m. in the morning
of Turin when it's [ __ ] intense and
then my dad used to work night shift at
the casino and I think in or near in the
room and it's all dark if it's only just
a glowing screen you can't pay attention
to anything right there just like like I
was super in the zone my dad comes home
he thought it would be funny to just
scare me cuz I can't see anything so he
calmed me goes blah I got so scared so
much of that face like four times
oh [ __ ] I was all [ __ ] my dad cuz you
know what you just get really you
thought you were getting attacked by oh
I don't even know what was happening
no one's happy remember that high school
happy Halloween [ __ ] the video that
was going around the guys in the trash
can yeah oh my god shocking the face
yeah you just be acting like Washington
so they take this high school right this
kid's gonna get interviewed with
something so that's the thing that
distracting him to set up behind him
it's this black sky right and then I
think behind him
this other dude pops up from a trash can
like that anyway a whole minute he fell
back in a trash can being open and then
closed like recently I'll show you guys
later but recently my friend showed me a
video of him scaring one of my friends
older brothers right so this dude name
is Daryl shoutout to you Daryl shoutout
Daryl Daryl Elsie since we were kids
this [ __ ] has loved Bruce Lee
like idolized him even moves like Bruce
Lee I don't think he's ever trained but
he's pretty [ __ ] fast right but
that's how obsessive he was just to give
you a picture of what this guy looks
like this fool has still works the same
with Ricker's that he's course it's like
the 10th grade he is 32 now oh yeah that
looks ridiculous it's back in style
all that swim breakers with like like
holes in the crotch and every ok now but
this will set me a bit of him scaring
him recently like are you're telling the
holes in the crotch like these two would
give a [ __ ] yeah that's right but they
scared they sent me a video of they
scared and right they jump from a bush
and it had like that nest cam [ __ ] this
fault still like [ __ ] with Bruce Lee so
much when he got scared
this will jump back you know dude I was
like [ __ ] Daryl dude still till this
day at the age of 32 he has that Bruce
Lee [ __ ] in him dude jump back and he
just went better than that other guy
that was like walking and then they
scare me he looks like he plays [ __ ]
computer games then he goes pull that
[ __ ] love Darrell shoutout to you man
when they go but they
then after they try to be all tough no
the best one is [ __ ] Josh [ __ ]
scare each other showing skids trying to
scare him in the dark all the time I
like my she wears a diary so I have to
do it very strategically right because I
know he might be a puncher
so like I have to have to figure out
where it is that he would punch so I try
to go lower than that or like further
back earlier I was in Monday I walked by
the conference room
and Gio was like crouched like this
there's all kind of scare me and you
would like making music so I'm like no
one else in this office cares to like
play like that so then I was like on the
floor like a [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
what's making like a drumming noise
because even if it wasn't Bart I'll be
like well this [ __ ] don't get
it stupid cause like I when we hide we
try to look cute - you know what I mean
so it's not just like regular hiding
it's like you party be joy take this
[ __ ] with these legs closed
all right maybe he moves really well I
was like I would do that someone open
the door of the back closed that [ __ ]
nice you ain't saying this you see my
size but Pepsi versus coke challenge I'm
just kidding elves and watch how these
[ __ ] couldn't scare me
[ __ ]
you just had a delayed reaction yeah you
know you know what actually happened I
didn't sleep at all
and so when you scared me it just didn't
register ly what you said in the video
oh yeah yeah you need to explain
yourself it's all really I don't [ __ ]
remember it was a long time ago or I GI
Jane let's continue your leprechaun ass
is gonna call me that this is not a
leprechaun green color though I'm sorry
totally leprechaun leprechaun green
Patrick scream you're all right this is
not this is cool green that's not cool
okay well you guys look like a military
couple right now I'm happy
oh yeah they imagine the new boys we
both look like we just woke up but you
guys aren't like both gyms see gym you
guys are gym rats all right so this
story here
this takes place in Nashville Tennessee
and there was this like haunted house
kind of thing like slasher fest or
whatever and this couple they were gone
or not a couple this group of friends
they were going to this haunted house
and then towards the end of it there was
this man this thin figure man with a
straw hat that asked one of the women if
one of her friends were like [ __ ]
around with her and then she said yes
and then he was like well then here
stabbed him handed her a real knife and
so she's like stabbed him in the arm and
then all of a sudden like gushing out
and like waiting and like there's a hole
in the shirt and like all this stuff and
then that's when they were like what the
[ __ ] I thought this was a prop cuz all
throughout the haunted house yeah I've
been given things so [ __ ] stupid why
the [ __ ] would he hand her a real knife
he said that it wasn't he didn't deal
with that sharp oh my god it's a nice
what do you have any of your house off
fleshes I can just stab someone with a
chopstick yeah I know somebody some dude
that [ __ ] stabbed up somebody in a
club with the end of a [ __ ] um this
ain't no no the [ __ ] fingernail
clipper the [ __ ] thing that way or
the beam that leg
right now little thing that filer the
hell yeah yeah hasta polari in
Sacramento ghetto ass [ __ ] club do
people [ __ ] they get toothbrush Italy
sharpen that [ __ ] and you can stab
somebody like I mean if you sharpen
anything else or if you've been my train
if you do the hot sand training it could
be slightly blunt - oh yeah it doesn't
have to be razor sharp like it Akina
[ __ ] stab someone with her [ __ ]
nails oh yeah she was just asking for
him to get up from the bathroom excuse
me Kill Bill was the last time you guys
went to a [ __ ] club hmm a club bar -
no I'm just saying apart be part be just
because like that remind you're like
stabbing his [ __ ] I went to a club like
a month ago because I relative that came
in she's young she wanted to go to a
club like in k-town or LA or whatever
and I couldn't go into the club because
I started getting nervous you know that
weird feeling that some shits always
about to go down I always get that at
every club yeah so I started getting
super [ __ ] nervous and [ __ ] just
because like well Sacramento when I when
I used to go to clubs I was like only a
step for my 18 - like 21 and you know
those 18 year old clubs were [ __ ]
ghetto as [ __ ] so I started you nervous
[ __ ] that somebody was gonna get jobs
somebody was gonna fight but that's what
happens like these young dudes they keep
staring at people they have that habit
of just like what sizing people down or
[ __ ] it's so weird like I don't [ __ ]
like without getting into a fight cuz
back in the day if you start looking you
stand somewhere too long maybe you know
k-town still like a little oh so and
plus like I'm not from LA so I don't
know anything so it just makes me feel
super [ __ ] nervous but that's [ __ ]
weird
it doesn't leave you I don't like love
no I thought on like clubs either man
when I go to a club always play
something's gonna go down so I'm like oh
I can't really like drink and have fun
and relax it's it's hard for me to do
this I don't want to mix alcohol and
youth because there's a rage involved
my friends were those people they are
talking about yeah see they actually
would cuz I'd be too so Brittany like
Brandon let's go can you drive us want
to [ __ ] somebody up alright yeah people
go to clubs just to fight just to look
for fights it's like oh why don't you go
talk to girls and [ __ ] you're trying to
impress then you see this yeah you like
that about they're from Oakland they're
[ __ ] the ghetto to opens for some
reason then they go to the club that's
what my friends all you see buddy up
that's how I did you let's get some
Korean barbecue and stab some people
typical Friday night go god damn I know
oh they're cool now though they're cool
now and then you get five after this
about the sacrament it's not even a club
I think it's considered a lounge but
it's I think it was an 18 / Club I don't
know how old I was but this is club
called polari out in Sacramento
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] dead oh [ __ ]
Hmong people so the Hmong people in
Sacramento would they would always go to
this club called polari and every
[ __ ] weekend without fail [ __ ]
fight somebody would get stabbed and
that's where that dude [ __ ] stabbed
the guy with the little toenail the
[ __ ] fingernail clipper thing and that
that's called viola right gonna file the
filer the filer thing nail file yeah I
think just anything that there's alcohol
it's there's like every weekend and it
was a cocktail waitress like every
single day on the weekend there was
always a fight like without fail oh yeah
every time dude [ __ ] even like in like
when you bar hop and in like on the
street where there's a lot of bars that
[ __ ] man there's always [ __ ] that goes
down man I don't know I I thought I was
gonna fight that one guy remember we're
at the kebee fight there's a guy who's
sitting in front of me and then he's
like yeah any times right he goes oh
yeah what you're gonna you gotta go he's
like you're gonna wear the khabib hat
and I'm McGregor shirt is that you gotta
make up your mind and then I was like I
like both equally they just kept staring
like he was Irish too right
I don't waited saving afters I didn't
skip staring the way there was no like
yeah that was probably too confused like
what's going on I'm too stupid to
register that's why I texted you I was
like there you guys okay just cuz I saw
his picture what if I to was before the
but hey everyone's already pre drinking
already so he just showed that he's just
like no I think if it wasn't for his
friend coming in getting this tractor
you probably would have kept staring
like oh [ __ ] I would he was sitting next
to you all right in front of me I could
just picture you and I want to kill them
because the the t-mobile is steep if you
wouldn't like it's so [ __ ] steep if
you go like this we just falling stories
oh they were at the very front of the
edge it's three rows were you scared no
I was scared
yeah it's really steeped alright no we
were when we were like trying to scoot
past those two people in the front
oh I even told the guy I'm like just
hold on I'm gonna take a while cuz it's
really scary
it was the steepest arena ever been
there's not a bad seat in that arena cuz
we're all the way to the top and we
could see the whole octagon like right
there like do you think you would allow
the guy to fall I pictured like you a
sock him in the face and you'll grab him
by his hair and you start doing this hey
come here for a second you just push his
forehead lightly hey how about this
[Music]
[Music]